you're looking at one of the most
incredible moments in human history
that's Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin
walking on the moon
okay maybe you've seen this clip before
but think about that for a second
they're on the moon a celestial object
nearly 240,000 miles into outer space
that distance is like flying all the way
around the earth nine and a half times
millions of people around the world
watched on July 16th 1969 as Apollo 11
carrying astronauts Neil Armstrong Buzz
Aldrin and Michael Collins launched from
Cape Kennedy Florida and disappeared
into the sky it was the climax of years
of preparation and research and the
pinnacle moment of the so-called space
race between the United States and
Soviet Union a year's long rivalry to
compete for dominance in space
exploration for the eight days following
the launch the world awaited the return
of the would-be heroes so what actually
happened between here and here let's
start with the components of the ship
that were discarded one by one until
this became this here's the rocket that
sent the astronauts into space the
saturn v the three stages of the saturn
v each played a different role in
launching apollo on a path to the moon
we'll get to that later
on top of the rocket is the actual
Apollo spacecraft it's made up of three
parts - there's the lunar module the
component that would eventually land on
the lunar surface
the service module which had propulsion
systems for course corrections and
entering and escaping orbit and the
command module where our three heroes
were for most of the mission and last
but not least this is the launch escape
system which was designed to pull the
command module away from the rocket if
something went wrong during launch
together all these pieces made up the
Saturn 5 rocket and Apollo 11 spacecraft
but it's the way they came apart that
made the moon landing happen
the Saturn 5's first stage launched
Apollo carrying the spacecraft 42 miles
above the earth and reaching a speed of
about 6,000 miles per hour the first
stage then detached and once the Saturn
5 second stage kicked in the now
needless launch escape system jettison
to the second stage propelled the
spacecraft even farther and faster into
space and after it detached the third
stage of the rocket fired briefly to
knock Apollo into a parking orbit 103
miles above the Earth's surface here
final checks were made and the Saturn 5
fired again to set Apollo on course to
the moon in a move called the translunar
injection once the spacecraft propelled
away from Earth the Saturn fives job was
done now the astronauts needed to pull
off a mid-flight maneuver to reconfigure
the ship so the crew could access the
lunar module which had been stored in a
protective compartment during launch to
do this the command service module
detached and flipped 180 degrees docking
with the lunar module and extracting it
in the process they ditched the third
now useless stage of the Saturn rocket
this whole high-stakes launch process
only took about three and a half hours
and this the completed Apollo spacecraft
was the end result for the next three
days
Apollo coasted through space until it
finally reached its target and was
pulled into orbit by the moon's gravity
this is where the crew split up
Armstrong and Aldrin transferred to the
lunar module named Eagle and slowly
descended toward the surface
while Collins continued to circle the
moon in the command module called
Columbia now here comes another tricky
part landing on the moon to make this
historic moment happen eagle turned and
used its engine to slow its momentum and
ultimately touchdown on the lunar
surface the moonwalk was broadcast live
on television immortalizing Neil
Armstrong's words here
I think that was Neils quote I didn't
understand one small step from lamb but
I didn't get the second phrase after
about 21 and a half hours on the moon
eagle performed the first launch from a
celestial body that wasn't earth leaving
its landing gear behind and timing its
ascent with Columbia's path in lunar
orbit to rejoin the spacecraft once I'm
Sean and Aldrin transferred back into
the command module the lunar module was
no longer needed
just like before Apollo needed to break
out of orbit this maneuver was called
the trans earth injection and began the
two-and-a-half day journey home upon
approaching its entry point into Earth's
atmosphere and no longer needing its
propulsion engines Apollo jettison the
service module and prepared for re-entry
protected by the now exposed to heat
shield on the bottom of the commandment
Apollo blazes across the heavens coming
back to earth at 25,000 miles an hour
parachutes deployed and Columbia
splashed down safely into the Pacific
Ocean and what was once a 3,000 ton
behemoth of rocket fuel and freight was
reduced to this a small command module
floating in the ocean carrying three
astronauts and rock samples collected
from the surface of the Moon
[Music]